[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian
sieers guten Abend ihn allen shny Luke
ist tot das ist seit heute Gewissheit
die 22-Jährige hatte feiern wollen das
Leben und die Liebe auf einem
Musikfestival sie wurde Opfer der
bestialischen Gewalt der hermass
Terroristen die die junge Frau die auch
einen deutschen Pass besitzt in den
Gazastreifen verschleppt hatten Menschen
aus 25 Nationen sind weiter in der
Gewalt der Islamisten über 230 von ihnen
vor welches Dilemma das die israelische
Gesellschaft stellt kann man auf den
Straßen des Landes sehen jeden Tag mehr
das ist Jerusalem heute jedes leere Bett
hier vor dem Rathaus steht symbolisch
für eine Geisel in Hamas Gefangenschaft
deren Angehörige appellieren an die
israelische Regierung zunächst das Leben
ihrer Liebsten über alles zu stellen
armit Metzger vermisst seine Großeltern
die aus einem kibutz entführt
wurden bevor wir über die Zerstörung der
Hamas reden oder Gaza diese ganze
Politik wir wollen sie nur raushen wir
wollen die mehr als 200 Menschen raus
aus Gas en
gaz der Premierminister Benjamin
Netanyahu ist dagegen heute Abend ganz
klar in seinen Absichten eine
Unterbrechung der Kämpfe in Gaza werde
es nicht geben er sagt das ist die Zeit
für Krieg Luk
walpot bis zuletzt hatte die Familie von
shaniny Luke auf eine positive Wendung
gehofft heute die erschütternde
Nachricht die junge Frau die mit mehr
als 200 anderen Menschen am 7 oktober
von Hamas Terroristen brutal entführt
worden war hat diesen Terror nicht
überlebt ich empfinde auf der einen
Seite Traurigkeit sagt ihre Mutter weil
es keine Chance gibt dass sie
zurückkommt auf der anderen Seite gibt
es Gewissheit was mit ihr passiert ist
sie hat wahrscheinlich nicht gelitten
sie ist ziemlich am Anfang
gestorben Bestürzung bei der einen
unbändige Freude bei der anderen Familie
die israelische Soldatin ori megidis
auch Sie von der Hamas verschleppt
konnte letzte Nacht vom Militär im
Gazastreifen befreit werden und verletzt
und wohl auf wie die Familie mitteilte
eine Erfolgsmeldung für Israels
Streitkräfte die nach eigenen Angaben
Schritt für Schritt ihre Operationen in
Gaza ausweiten man habe über Nacht
zahlreiche Terroristen getötet heißt es
anwohner berichteten von schweren
Luftangriffen Feuergefechten und
panzerbewegungen die massiven
Zerstörungen der Kämpfe sind deutlich
sichtbar die humanitäre Situation
verschlimmert sich obwohl gestern nach
Angaben der Vereinten Nationen ein
größerer Konvoi hilfslastwagen die
Grenze nach Gaza überquert hat trotz der
dringenden Aufrufe der israelischen
Armee Gaza Stadt zu verlassen haben sich
allein am schifahkrankenhaus dem größten
der Stadt mehr als 50.000 Bewohner
versammelt um Schutz vor Angriffen zu
suchen Israels Armee wirft der Hamas vor
unter dem Hospital kommandotunnel zu
betreiben das ist hier immer noch der
sicherste Ort für uns die Israel sagen
sie werden das Hospital angreifen ob sie
es tun oder nicht macht keinen
Unterschied wir werden ja alle als
mertürer sterben die Hamas
veröffentlichte heute Aufnahmen von drei
weiblichen Geiseln die Regierungschef
Netanyahu scharf kritisieren und einen
sofortigen Gefangenen Austausch
fordern grausame psychologische
Propaganda der Terroristen so die
Antwort des Ministerpräsidenten er lasse
sich nicht von seinem Kurs
abbringen ich verstehe die Sorgen der
Angehörigen voll und ganz aber unsere
Einschätzung auch die der Armee ist dass
die Bodenoperationen eine Möglichkeit
schaffen für die Freilassung eine
Möglichkeit wenn auch keine
gewisshit die Familien der Geiseln sehen
das anders und nicht nur sie der Druck
auf den Regierungschef
wächst die Befreiung von Geiseln aus dem
Gazastreifen kaum jemand kennt sich
damit besser aus als gerschon Baskin das
ist sein Lebensthema spätestens seit er
Vermittler war um den entführten
Soldaten gilat schalid freiubekommen
damals nach fünf langen Jahren Herr
Baskin schön dass Sie bei uns sind
vielen Dank und guten Abend thank you
ich danke ihnen sie sind aktuell nicht
in offizieller Mission unterwegs haben
aber weiter Kontakt zu Leuten von der
Hamas deswegen die allerwichtigste Frage
zuerst wissen Sie wie es den Geiseln
geht
also man hat mir nicht gesagt wie es
Ihnen geht abgesehen von diesem
Videofilm es ist einfach Teil dieses
psychologischen Krieges den ramas führt
gingüber Israel in diesem Video wurden
ja drei Frauen gezeigt und so soll eben
der Druck auf die israelische
Gesellschaften auf die Gesellschaft erht
und auf die Regierung erhöt werden um
einfach ein Deal zu
machen und die Geisen auszutauschen
Gen
dieang isischenfä das scheint im
Hintergrund verhandelt zu werden aber es
gibt große fragezeugen hinterde was
passieren wird mit Terroristen redet man
nicht Punkt sagen manche warum tun sie
das
trotzdem jeder verhandelt mit
Terroristen man nicht
miten
aber israelische Zivilisten Bürger
werden von Hamas man muss mit denen
sprechen
israelicht nicht direkt mit has und
Hamas auch nicht man benutzt also
Unterhändler die Ägypter vor allen
Dingen auch die Kataris dort finden die
Gespräche statt den Israel und Hamas
sprechen miter was traurig ist den das
wä ja das einfachste um eine
Verhandlungslösung zu finden
und so braucht man nicht diese
umständlichen Verhandlungswege wen man
nicht direkt miteinander redet diese
umständlichen Verhandlungswege sie haben
es gerade angesprochen Ägypten Katar es
gibt Berichte darüber dass israelische
regierungsflugzeuge hin und her
unterwegs sind zwischen Tel Aviv und
Doha in Katar der
mossatchef also der Geheimdienstchef in
Israel Auen Auen
auslandsgeheimdienstchef der soll in
Doha gewesen sein wie viel
Erfolgschancen geben Sie Al dem denn
aktuell
ursprülich sprach man ja über einen
kleinen
de Geiseln gegen andere ich wäre
optimistisch über die Kinder Mütter
älteren Leute Verwundeten da könnte ich
eher in Mölichkeit
sehen jetzt scheinen bei die Gedanken zu
sein haben will alle Gefangenen gegen
alle
Geiseln wir sehen jetzt keine Situation
wo einige rausgeschickt werden und
einige bleiben entweder ein Deal für
alle oder gar kein Deal die Zeit läuft
und die Militäroperation am Boden ist
hat begonnen und da geht's auch drum
Druck auszuüben auf Hamas aber wenn
erstmal die Armee reingeht mit
attillerie und Panzern und spezialkräen
dann dann schließ sich wahrscheinlich
das Fenster für die handlungen das
Fenster für die Verhandlung schließt
sich dann sagen sie der israelische
Regierungschef benjamin netanahu hat
heute abend gesagt gerade durch diese
Offensive die aktuell stattfindet im
Gazastreifen könne den Geiseln eher
geholfen werden wie sehen Sie das aus
aus ihrer
Erfahrung ich glaube nicht dass
irgendjemand mit so einer Situation
Erfahrung hat so etwas hat es bisher
noch nicht gegeben das Konzept das Druck
auf funktioniert mag vielleicht
funktionieren dass sie vielleicht
Umdenken es könnte vielleicht dazu
führen wenn man Druck ausübt dass es
einen Deal gibt aber es kann einfach
auch dazu führen dass man die Geiseln in
den Tunneln behält als menschliche
schutzschildde wenn die israelische
Armee herausfindet wo die
Kommandozentralen sind wo die Kämpfer
sind dann wollte die sich wahrscheinlich
hinter den Geiseln
verschanzen Herr BK noch mal zurück zu
gilard schalid diesen Rekruten diesen
Soldaten bei dem sie damals mitgeholfen
haben ihn wieder freiubekommen aus
hamashaft damals wurden über 1000
palästinensische Häftlinge im Gegenzug
eingetauscht ist sowas heute noch mal
denkbar wir sprechen über die
Möglichkeit eines
dis all
diese gegen 6 bis 7000 Palästinenser und
darunter sind
559 Palästinenser in die lebenslälich
bekommen haben wenn wir all die Geiseln
rausbekommen wollen oder dass sie
verletzt werden zurück nach Hause sicher
dann müssen wir eventuell so einen Deal
machen und Israel wird sich dann mit den
Konsequenzen abfinden müssen wenn 6 bis
7000 Gefangene freigelassen werden nach
Gaza in die West oder ausgewiesen werden
ganz kurz noch Herr Baskin bei all dem
was wir gerade hören kann man wirklich
jede Hoffnung verlieren wie behalten sie
ihre
Hoffnung jedes Menschenleben dass ich
helfen kann zu retten ist eine ganze
Welt ein ganzes Universum und darauf
müssen wir uns konzentrieren wir müssen
versuchen Menschenleben hier zu retten
und ich ma mir auch Gedanken über die
Menschen über die unschuldigen Menschen
in Gaza die
W alsat dessen was gemacht hat und wir
sollten Menschenleben iner ganzen Region
retten sagt ja schon Baskin her Baskin
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch heute
abend thank ich danke
ihnen wir bleiben hier in der Sendung
noch beim Thema im weitesten Sinne
zumindest mit dir jetzt Hanna nach den
gewaltsamen judenfeindlichen
Ausschreitungen auf einem Flughafen in
der russischen Teilrepublik Dagestan
sind 60 Personen festgenommen worden
gestern abend hatten hunderte Menschen
das Flughafengebäude und das Rollfeld
gestürmt nachdem ein Flugzeug aus Israel
gelandet war laut Behörden wurden
mindestens 20 Personen verletzt der
russische Präsident Putin machte heute
den Westen und die Ukraine für die
Krawalle verantwortlich ohne Belege
vorzulegen laut dem Bundeskriminalamt
sind im vergangenen Jahr mehr als 17 000
Kinder unter 14 Jahren Opfer von
sexualisierter Gewalt geworden fast
jedes siebte sei jünger als 6 Jahre alt
gewesen damit bleibt die Zahl der
erfassten Taten auf einem hohen Niveau
das BKA geht zudem von einem großen
Dunkelfeld aus Opfer und Tatverdächtige
kannten sich in mehr als der Hälfte der
Fälle z.B durch Verwandtschaft oder
Freundschaft gut zwei Jahre nach der
Flutkatastrophe im Aartal hat eine
Kommission des reinandfelsischen
Landtags ihren Abschlussbericht
vorgelegt im Fokus dabei Maßnahmen für
für einen besseren
extremwetterschutz demnach sollten unter
anderem Deiche erhöht und
Überflutungsgebiete ausgedehnt werden
außerdem werden die Kommunen aufgerufen
beim Hochwasserschutz stärker
zusammenzuarbeiten bei den
Überschwemmungen 2021 waren allein in
Rheinlandpfalz
136 Menschen ums Leben gekommen
bundesinnenministerin ferser ist zu
Gesprächen nach Marokko gereist und hat
dort eine Vereinbarung über mehr
Zusammenarbeit bei den Themen Migration
und Abschiebung getroffen mit ihrem
marokkanischen Amtskollegen LAF Tiet
unterzeichnete fäser eine entsprechende
Absichtserklärung bislang hatte Marokko
wenig Interesse an der Rückführung
seiner Staatsbürger das soll sich nun
ändern Deutschland will im Gegenzug die
legale Migration und Einwanderung von
Fachkräften stärken sowie gemeinsam mit
Marokko Terrorismus und
schleuserkriminalität
bekämpfen Afrika ist gerade Ziel einer
ganzen Reihe von polit besuchen aus
Deutschland die Innenministerin haben
wir ja gerade gehört der Bundespräsident
reist diese Woche ebenfalls das war ja
jahrelang komplett anders jetzt ist
Afrika wichtig geworden oder besser
gesagt jetzt haben wir gemerkt dass
Afrika wichtig ist und zwar gleich aus
mehreren Gründen aus Afrika kommen viele
Flüchtlinge nach Europa aus Afrika
kommen auch Rohstoffe zu uns Öl und Gas
nigeria ist das Land in Afrika mit den
meisten Einwohnern dort ist der
Bundeskanzler zu Gast und Andreas Kü
beobachtet
ihn das da drüben am Ufer ist die
niegelnagel neue Metrolinie der 20
Millionen Stadt Lagos sie wurde von den
Chinesen gebaut china baut seit Jahren
in Lagos in Nigeria in Afrika das da
vorne in Bötchen ist der deutsche
Bundeskanzler Deutschland ist spät in
Nigeria spät in Afrika aber Scholz
findet nicht zu spät dass die
Lokalpresse schimpft weil die Chinesen
schon weg aber noch Fragen zur Metro
offen sind sowas meint der Gast aus
Berlin dass das nicht nur ein schnelles
Geschäft ist dass man irgendwo gemacht
hat und wo man das Land in dem man
irgendwas hingeliefert hat oder gebaut
hat wieder verlässt sondern wo es darum
geht langfristig gute Partnerschaften
die auf Qualität beruhen und auf dem was
dann auch die Eigenentwicklung der
Länder fördert das ist das deutsche
Modell das deutsche Modell ist Olaf
Scholz wichtig es gibt für scheinbar
jede Krise
und wegen der flüchtlingskrise ist
Scholz hier in diesem grünen Hinterhof
versucht Deutschland jenen Nigerianern
zu helfen die es nach Europa geschafft
hatten aber zurück mussten für den wir
müssen endlich im großen Stil abschieben
Kanzler ein
Erfolgsmodell es ist gut wenn diese
Rückkehrer eine Zukunft haben ein
Einkommen einen Job oder die Chance ein
kleines Geschäft zu
gründen rund 800 aus Deutschland
abgeschobene Migranten haben mit Hilfe
des
remigrationszentrums Germany einen Job
gefunden 800 Einwohner von 200 Millionen
bis 2050 wird Nigeria eine größere
Bevölkerung als die EU haben eine halbe
Milliarde und die Hälfte von ihnen wird
jung sein jünger als 20 Präsident
bolotinubu erklärt sich zwar regelmäßig
bereit seine ausreisepflichtigen
Staatsbürger aus Deutschland
zurückzunehmen das Problem sind die
Staatsbürger die ihre Pässe
wegwerfen ich stelle keine Bedingungen
wenn es Nigerianer sind dann sind es
Nigerianer und sie sind wieder zu Hause
willkommen für Fachkräfte Handwerker für
Talente bietet Scholz so viele legale
Wege in Deutschland zu arbeiten wie noch
nie aber die illegalen sollen Nigeria
zurücknehmen weil sie einen irregulären
Weg gewählt haben und obwohl sie ganz
andere Perspektiven verfolgen versucht
haben sich auf
asylschutzgründe zu berufen was nicht
gelingen konnte am Abend wird Scholz
weiterschippern ins nächste afrikanische
Land nach Ghana Deutschland ist spät
aber Scholz sagt nicht zu
spät ein Ritual heute in München und
gleichzeitig etwas noch nie da gewesen
ist der Plenarsaal des Bayerischen
Landtags füllt sich mit den frisch
gewählten ab ordneten und das heißt mit
einer erstarkten AFD mit einer
Regierungskoalition wieder aus CSU und
Freien Wähler traditionell auch dass der
Alterspräsident die Sitzung eröffnet
diesmal allerdings mit mahnenden Worten
was wir in den letzten Monaten gesehen
und gehört haben steht in unserem
schönen Bayern nicht zu
Gesicht an seiner Seite soll eigentlich
der jüngste Abgeordnete sitzen auch das
ist Tradition aber Daniel hemba 22 Jahre
alt von der AFD fehlt er wird seit Tagen
mit Haftbefehl gesucht und ist heute von
der Polizei festgenommen worden Simon
Fanzelt es ist eine alte Tradition dass
die Namen aller Abgeordneten verlesen
werden wenn in Bayern ein neugewählter
Landtag zusammenkommt was es aber noch
nie gegeben hat ist dass sich fast die
gesamte konstituierende Sitzung um einen
Mann dreht der gar nicht da ist Daniel
entschuldigt Freitag hatten die Behörden
per Haftbefehl nach dem AFD Abgeordneten
hallember gesucht die Staatsanwaltschaft
wirft ihm Volksverhetzung und die
Verwendung verfassungsfeindlicher
Symbole vor heute morgen wurde er
verhaftet und lässt seinen Anwalt ein
Video voller Verschwörungen
verbreiten das ist ein weiterer
trauriger Höhepunkt der Jagd der CSU auf
die demokratische Opposition unser Volk
für dieses Schauspiel durchschauen und
schon bald den notwendigen Machtwechsel
in der Politik
herbeiführen seit der Landtagswahl
stellt sich die Frage wie die AFD als
Oppositionsführerin agiert und wie die
anderen mit dieser Oppositionsführerin
umgehen darum geht es auch als der
Alterspräsident die Sitzung heute
eröffnet wir ernten was wir
sehen wer Zwietracht zwischen den
Menschen seätt wird ein gespaltenes Land
ernten wer Falschbehauptungen aufstellt
wird Vertrauen verlieren Populismus
trennt immer er verbindet
nie dieser konstituierenden Sitzung
liefert einen Vorgeschmack wie die
nächsten Jahre klingen
dürften unabhängig von allen
strafrechtlichen Bewertungen der
Vorgänge wird hier ein gewähltes
Mitglied dieses Hauses durch eine AD HCK
Entscheidung der Behörden nur wenige
Tage vor dieser Sitzung von der
Mandatsausübung abgehalten das ist ein
absoluter Skandal für eine Demokratie in
Bayern ich bin der Meinung wir leben in
einer absolut schützenswerten und auch
guten Demokratie denn jemand der
Verfassungs feindliche Äußerung maach
der gehört eingesperrt und nicht in
dieses Parlament liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Gipfel der Unverschämtheit
ist es dass die AFD die Justiz
lächerlich macht ich sage es deutlich
ich schäme mich für das Bild das wir
hier abgeben die AFD inszeniert sich als
Opfer einer politischen Justiz alle
anderen halten dagegen ein Muster das
sich durch diese Legislatur ziehen
dürfte das legen die Worte der
wiedergewählten Landtagspräsidentin nahe
erst waren es die Medien dann war es der
Verfassungsschutz und jetzt ist es die
Justiz was kommt denn eigentlich als
nächstes ich erkenne die Inszenierung in
diesen Angriffen die Täter Opfer Umkehr
als Muster mit völkisem Unterton mit dem
Ziel das Vertrauen in die demokratischen
Institutionen zu
zerstören am Abend hebt der Landtag die
Immunität des Abgeordneten hembember auf
die AFD enthält sich später wird bekannt
dass die von der AFD so gescholtene
Justiz den Haftbefehl außer Vollzug
gesetzt hat auch erledigt so jetzt ein
Thema das uns ja alle seit vielen
Monaten umtreibt wo geht all das Geld
hin eins ist sicher es kommt nicht
wieder aber es gibt jetzt zumindest
positivere Nachrichten bei dir Hanna ja
denn die Inflationsrate in Deutschland
ist im Oktober ein weiteres Mal gesunken
und zwar deutlich auf
3,8%. das hat das Statistische Bundesamt
heute auf Grundlage von vorläufigen
Zahlen mitgeteilt Valerie Haller ist das
jetzt das der extremen Teuerung die wir
in den vergangenen Jahren erlebt haben
ja also das ist zumindest mal der
niedrigste Stand seit über zwei Jahren
und ein weiterer deutlicher Rückgang der
Inflation Energie wurde etwas günstiger
Lebensmittel aber bleiben teuer
allerdings macht sich jetzt auch der
sogenannte basisffekt bemerkbar die
Preise für Energie und Nahrungsmittel
waren vor einem Jahr stark gestiegen und
das drückt die Inflationsrate im
Vergleich zu diesem Jahr entsprechend
die Aussichten eher durchwachsen die
teure Energie und und ein kräftiger
Lohnanstieg bleiben potentielle
Preistreiber bis hier also Stabilität
erreicht es dürfte es noch dauern und
dann gab es heute auch noch frische
Zahlen zum brutto Inlandsprodukt wie
sind die ausgefallen also das ist jetzt
erstmal nur eine Schätzung demnach ist
die Konjunktur im dritten Quartal um
0,1% geschrumpft nachdem es in der
ersten Jahreshälfte schon kaum Wachstum
gab bedeutet dass die deutsche
Wirtschaft tritt mehr oder weniger auf
der Stelle Gründe gibt es viele hohe
Zinsen gestiegene Materialkosten und
eine schwache
Weltkonjunktur am Ende des laufenden
Winterhalbjahres dürfte ein Minus stehen
die Ökonomen also die setzen jetzt auf
2024 vielen Dank Valerie für diese
Einordnungen bei einem schweren Unfall
in der Hamburger Hafencity sind vier
Bauarbeiter ums Leben gekommen ein
weiterer wurde lebensgefährlich verletzt
am Morgen war ein Gerüst in einem
Fahrstuhlschacht im Inneren des geb
zusammengebrochen mehrere Arbeiter
stürzten bis zu acht Stockwerke in die
Tiefe wie es zu dem Unglück kam ist noch
unklar die FIFA hat den ehemaligen
spanischen Verbandspräsidenten rubiales
nach dem kussskandal bei der WM
Siegerehrung für 3 Jahre gespert
betroffen sind davon Tätigkeiten auf
nationaler und internationaler Ebene
Entscheidung hat die FIFA
Disziplinarkommission getroffen riales
hatte im August nach dem WM Triumph der
spanischen Fußballfrauen die Spielerin
hermoso ohne ihre Zustimmung auf den
Mund
geküsst sie alle und noch mal besonders
die die manchmal verzweifeln bei der
Suche nach einem Auto mit Zukunft das
fährt und zwar umweltfreundlich aber
ohne dass man ständig Bang blicken muss
auf den Zustand der Batterie und die
ladesäuleninfrastruktur in Deutschland
sie alle nehmen wir jetzt mit und zwar
nach Australien einmal von Nord nach Süd
quer durchs Outback über 3000 km auf dem
Stuart Highway menschenleere Steppen und
Wüstenlandschaft aber garantiert
Sonnenschein Schauplatz des wohl
härtesten Langstrecken Rennens der Welt
für
E-Autos und damit bedeutet das nicht nur
Spaß und Abenteuer sondern ist auch ein
Blick in unsere automobile Zukunft
luthercker ist
dort
aus aller Welt sind 38 Teams mit ihren
solarrennwagen in dvin angetreten
darunter auch das Team Sonnenwagen aus
Aachen die Studierenden haben ihr
Solarauto adelie getauft wenn das Auto
das erste Mal wirklich in den Kampf mit
den anderen Teams geht dann ist das
natürlich ein Moment auf den wir alle
hingefiebert haben zi Jahre drauf hin
gearbeitet haben adelie schlägt sich gut
das Team Sonnenwagen fährt im Qualifying
auf Platz 1 Position für das
Langstreckenrennen
als Sachverständiger und Beobachter ist
Markus machazzi vom tüvnord nach
Australien gereist für ihn ist die World
sol Challenge die ideale Herausforderung
für Studierende ihr Können unter Beweis
zu stellen bei den Studierenden geht's
darum was habe ich gerade gelernt
theoretisch wie kann ich das praktisch
umsetzen weil die Leute die unsere
Elektrofahrzeuge die jetzt schon auf der
Straße sind konstruiert haben waren
vielleicht sogar mal Studenten die diese
Fahrzeuge gebaut haben deswegen passt
das schon alles ganz gut
zusammen dann es auf die 3000 km lange
Strecke nach
edyade schon am ersten Tag sortiert sich
das Feld die Topteams aus Belgien und
den Niederlanden setzen sich an die
Spitze in Abständen von rund 300 km
müssen die Teams an Kontrollstellen eine
exakt 30minütige zwagspause einlegen
samt
Fahrerwechsel teils über 700 km schaffen
die solarrennwagen so jeden Tag auf dem
Stuart Highway dem Asphaltband das den
australischen Kontinent von Nord nach
Süd durchquert gefahren wird jeden Tag
von 8 bis 17 Uhr wo auch immer das
Rennteam dann ist schlagen die
Studierenden ihr Zeltlager auf und
richten die Solarpanele optimal zur
Sonne
aus wir generieren auch Energie wenn wir
normal fahren aber der Winkel ist
natürlich nicht optimal wenn der Winkel
optimal ist haben wir angestellt so wie
jetzt das können wir nur machen wenn wir
stehen deswegen sind das die wichtigsten
Stunden die wir im Rennen haben wo auch
jedes Team drauf ist dass da keine
Minute verloren geht weil es eben die
Energie reinbringt starke Seitenwinde im
out Outback machen den Solarautos zu
schaffen am fünften Tag des Rennens nach
gut 2700 km das Aus für Team Sonnenwagen
adelie ist von der Straße geschleudert
Fahrer und Fahrzeug kommen mit ein paar
Schrammen davon doch der Unfall bedeutet
Disqualifikation gewonnen hat am Ende
das Team der Uni leuen aus Belgien
durchs Ziel in edilade darf adelie
dennoch fahren sie ist zwar nicht das
schnellste Solarauto aber wohl eins der
stabilsten in zwei Jahren will das Team
Sonnenwagen in neuer Besetzung wieder in
Australien an den Start
gehen süß auf jeden Fall oder unser
Reporter Klang auch so ein bisschen so
als ob er in einem dieser mobile drin
saß das werden wir gleich noch mal
klären und bei Ihnen sagen wir danke für
Ihr Interesse und empfehlen Ihnen noch
unser heute journal Update gegen 0:10
Uhr mit nasan G mir von uns allen hier
im Team an sie einen angenehmen Abend
tschüss
[Musik]
tschüss schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter der Oktober ist ja
nun fast vorbei und was schon mal klar
ist es ist einer der fünf wärmsten
oktoberm Monate seit 1881 und der
nasseste seit
2002 ja warm und nass geht's ja im
Prinzip weiter mit diesem Tief hier z.B
was uns nordostwärts überquert und Regen
bringt aber danach im Tagesverlauf
lockert es auf und mit Schauern von
Südwesten müssen wir aber weiterhin
rechnen dann Richtung Alpen gibt's noch
ein Tief was hier Regen und Schnee
bringt drückt die Wolken an die Alpen
ran verlagert sich aber dann auch im
Tagesverlauf Ost wärts in der Nacht also
Regen der allmählich nordostwärts zieht
von Südwesten her lockert es auf und die
Temperaturen gehen dabei zurück auf 6°
an den Alpen und 12° ganz im Osten
Deutschlands im Tagesverlauf morgen dann
weiterer Regen der in Bändern hier
allmählich nach Nordosten wandert ja von
Westen her und im Süden da gibt's auch
Schauer ansonsten dazwischen auch
Auflockerung auch mal trockene
Abschnitte mit etwas Sonne Temperaturen
dazu die höchsten te 14° ganz im Westen
im Rhein meineebiet und im Südwesten
Deutschlands am kühlsten noch an den
Alpen z.B mit 9° und die nächsten Tage
ja am Mittwoch lockert es auch vor allem
im Süden viel Sonnenschein im Nordwesten
dagegen Regen bei 10 bis 17° und am
Donnerstag gibt's im Nordwesten
Regenwetter mit Sturm und damit einen
schönen
Abend